coach Richie Carney Denver Sports you
told the world on game day to keep the
cameras rolling right you and Jay would
meet post-game right when Jay was asked
about it earlier he said about what
maybe went on or what was said he said
you can ask Prime about that so is there
anything meaningful no no I know kind of
got in between it but no I don't man I
don't hold
you know I could be Petty if they Petty
but I ain't I ain't got time for that
man I'm on to bigger things hey I'm
happy for the brother I really am and
I'm happy that they thought that they
played a good game I'm happy he's a head
coach I'm happy for any brother that's
doing it and successful man I truly am I
don't I don't know where all this stuff
come from I have to respond because you
know it's my mama told me that you know
you just ain't gonna type me and I'm
gonna sit back and ain't gonna say
nothing but I'm happy for that dude man
I don't know him
that I'm happy for I wish the best for
him I really do nothing My Success ain't
got nothing to do with his so why would
I want him to succeed I don't know how
people get down like that my blessings
ain't got nothing to do with his
blessings